you're a cop in everything but name
saving Gotham's not my job anymore I do
this there's no turning back no there
isn't
GCPD is not Gotham Gotham listens to me
[Music]
or big girls we can handle ourselves
that was awesome
[Music]
I want an arm
an army like me I don't think autumns
running out of monsters anytime soon
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so Killer Croc
bunch of other monsters from Batman's
rogues gallery coming to Gotham this
season let's break it down there's
actually a bunch of characters and this
is like the monster season if you didn't
see season 2 of Gotham at the end
it'd be like bus like a truckload full
of inmates at Arkham they were all being
worked on by Hugo Strange got out
including like the mysterious
doppelganger of Bruce Wayne so I know a
lot of people are like wait a minute
does that mean they're doing like a huh
shark because they've already done
Thomas Eliot and he was a different
character this might be like a minor
course correction to that because they
are doing court of owls
so like when he says there's no turning
back like when he's getting ready to do
something he's basically saying that
he's building out the Batman persona by
building the mask that is Bruce Wayne
like the douchey rich guy that drives
around in fancy cars goes to parties
acts very differently from the dark
brooding true self of Bruce Wayne like
Batman is the real Bruce Wayne
figuratively when the cowl comes off the
mask goes on so that's going to start
happening this season and to talk about
Killer Croc here because I know everyone
saw Suicide Squad they're like hey wait
a minute where's the scales so what I
think is going on here is that they're
just showing him in an earlier stage of
mutation like he didn't go from zero to
the way he looks right here overnight
they took a little bit of time so in the
way that Bruce Wayne is like slowly
becoming Batman over the course of this
series of a crock also slowly becoming
like the full crocodile self that he's
going to be eventually but if you guys
did wonder Killer Croc during Suicide
Squad that was practical effects like he
actually walked around with that makeup
on it wasn't like a full CG character
like say King shark or Gorilla Grodd but
we got Bruce here probably being intro
to the court of owls this person here
with the knife might be one of the
talents but remains to be seen because
fish Mooney's outfit actually resembles
the talons armor from the comics so
remains to be seen when it comes to
court of owls this is what the actual
owl masks look like though adult poison
ivy
I think the way they're explaining her
getting older super fast is that it's
the same character but she goes through
like a metamorphosis like she does in
the comics in the animated series so she
just comes out looking like this Hugo
Strange locked up so experimenting
probably going to play with even more
monster
years in barbara so here's the thing
about barbara so in previous seasons we
you know when she started to go like
crazy when she flew off the deep-end at
the end of season one I was like maybe
they're gonna turn her into like the
show's version of Harley Quinn season
two went by net you know none of that
stuff happened she just got crazier and
crazier so it's like okay she's a crazy
person who is from the comics but not
like her comic book self but then at
Comic Con this year the showrunners are
like Harley Quinn is already on the show
he says that the person that they're
turning into Harley Quinn hasn't become
Harley Quinn yet so I was like oh yeah
they're probably talking about Barbara
very clearly she has the Harley Quinn
persona like I'm free from the shackles
of what society has told me the way I'm
supposed to act I'm just gonna do
whatever I want
I've been completely free that was like
all what she did last season when she
got out of Arkham she was like
assaulting Jim Gordon with this new self
that she's become so I think that she's
like the show's version of Harley Quinn
but you guys can let me know in the
comments what do you think about like
the monsters season of Gotham now
obviously a lot of Batman villains are
monsters so they are pushing deeper into
comic book stuff but it does seem like
they're taking their time and going to
straight-up Batman comic book stuff
because the showrunner made some
comments about costumes and make it like
you know monster makeup that I don't
necessarily agree with he's like yeah
you know I don't think it totally works
so I don't necessarily agree with that
like you can totally have a comic book
II TV show just as long as say like TV
Bruce Wayne is true to comic book Bruce
Wayne so it's really the way the
characters are written to performance
the tone that's important the costumes
the way it looks not quite as important
although I will say like even if you're
going to do like a tone down or less
evolved version of a character like oh
this is this character before some of
this stuff had happened you still want
to be relatively true to that costume in
the comics like Jesse quick on the flash
for instance they introduced that
character during season two but you know
she did have speed force powers season
three she's coming back people saw her
on set recently and said that she's
wearing a version of her comic book
costume
they didn't say if it's the red Jesse
quit costume or if it's the blue Liberty
Bell costume but still even if she
doesn't have Speed Force powers she
still looks very much like her comic
book self so I think as long as Gotham
stays relatively true to
the characters and some of the look and
the tone of the characters from the
comics I think it'll be fine but I'm not
planning on doing weekly videos for the
episodes just because so much is
happening like they have Superman on
Supergirl in the same timeslot on
Mondays so of course my attentions going
to be focused on Superman but if there
is anything really notable that happens
on Gotham I'll totally do a video for it
I'll probably at least do a video for
the first episode so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff there is
a new round of the DC giveaway that's
going in now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video there's been a whole bunch of
DC stuff happening this week mostly
because of Deathstroke Batman stuff but
I do think it's interesting that the
Gotham TV show is able to do some Batman
characters that they're doing in the
movies so I don't know if Jeff Jones is
responsible or what's going on behind
the scenes at Warner Brothers but it
seems like they're loosening up on the
TV shows doing movie characters so I'm
actually really happy about that like
Mad Hatter is a good example he's going
to be on the TV show this season he'll
be the guy from walking dead who played
that wolf during season 5 don't worry if
you didn't watch Walking Dead he's just
being played by an actor who actually
looks legitimately crazy in real life so
we'll see how it goes I'm really curious
about Gotham this season they're
definitely a couple of actors like big
actors on the show that I really do not
like but even if I'm not doing videos
for it like I still watch it week to
week so if you're big Batman fan lots of
Batman stuff happening on Gotham this
season next video later tonight we'll
probably be guardians of the galaxy to
Vin Diesel was fangirling over preview
that he got to watch it's like the most
hilarious thing ever so he and James
Gunn do this big video so I'll do video
for that later tonight while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to watch Vin Diesel fangirl on Avengers
infinity war Guardians crossover and you
can click here to learn all about Jessie
quick on the flash season 3 thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you